[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you got a second Oh for you took us took
us up hello sorry I didn't realize I
took the mics up but uh hey we have a
special livestream today because I'm
back on live streams it's been a while
I'd turn us both up okay yeah my bet now
you're good all right
there you go oh cool all right we have a
special livestream today because I'm on
it's been a while but uh my boy Erik
Tate here Bromley in last minute because
we got Final Fantasy 10 and Final
Fantasy 10 to unintended HD remasters
yeah so it's gonna be looking real nice
when you're playing on yeah but okay so
we're gonna see Rhodes have you seen
that I've extra master before yeah I
played on well I played on Vita okay so
you know how this works right like all
the main characters are remastered and
yeah okay it was uncanny valley kind of
stuff alright let's hop into it I'm
gonna start a new game cool cool turn up
the gameplay on this guy yeah we're four
five I mean the games were well I won't
stand I don't remember the most
dude Sphere Grid original right we want
original yeah oh yeah let's just do
original right all right let us play the
original I don't want the arranged stuff
I'm sure it sounds dope though oh can
you show that that's fine
oh yeah just use the f-word but that's
okay nice Salomon
all right salmon or Salomon salmon Ellis
Island okay sound oh man alright I was
talking to tell you earlier but when we
boot this up enters it enters an arcane
was V song in middle school for me
mmm-hmm that's what everyone wanted to
play on piano
[Music]
there's like they played this song oh I
totally forgot about my boy ah you put
the wolf boy kini Maru right yeah like
all right so I'm gonna pull up a
Wikipedia page because like I played
Final Fantasy 10 like five times he's
the only one I forgot cuz like when I
was writing out search terms I wrote
down every character except the boy I
will call him it's Kimmy something
kimimaro yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna pull
up what we compete a page for this
because trust me I played five phases
ten like a bunch of times but for the
life of me I can't remember because I
think the last time I play it was almost
16 first play wants ten I figured out
the sphere great because I was I don't
think I'm gonna get far enough where he
goes I know fake it's a fake ass laughs
yeah that's pretty that's pretty deep in
the game that's like three or four hours
I guess we're probably so we're gonna do
like 45 minutes ish of ten and then
we'll do like 45 minutes ten - it's all
this is not as good as ten though yeah
that's true it was fanservice yeah but
I'm kind of into that good he looks
but but we're talking about how he was
probably the most wack out of all the
atom so the final fantasy 10 cast is
like by and large like really dope so I
think that's what mate is like and I
guess I say teenis because itís I said
Titus because I watched that TV show
back in the day that's dope so I got to
my story
oh and the thing is voice acting has it
well maybe our last chance did I play
this in English yeah really cuz I
probably did I probably did I don't
think it did if I probably did and I
just like I can't like let it go gray
fox is asking for blitzball we're not
going we're not well oh yeah dude it
seems legit yeah you got some death
metal and blitzball baby seen this
opening cutscene is yeah I was like dog
Final Fantasy is about that life yeah I
know
dude I was like what is this Slipknot
[ __ ] okay yeah so you can see the
character models or yeah they're not
that's a standard kid kid a so Titus not
t2c okay so Chris pirata who is somebody
who has just joined yeah gamespot more
to help us with Twitter
he says Tita stew and he said he worked
on helping bring this one out right yeah
and so I don't know cuz he was with
square right yeah or on his daddy and I
love war on suggest baby
hey oh look it's me it's your boy is
titãs because the characters call him
that that's how the characters pronounce
his name but person titus I'm really I
would say Titus because that's something
right I can't do it yeah all right so
we'll go Titus no matter what oh you
sure can oh so girl hell yeah
alright alright we're just gonna creep
named Titus or Titus I'm not gonna say
it has an age wall and say it's it's
different now Bob Jones what's up baby I
know so the thing about like you have to
do all this remember the thing about
older file fancies like there's no way
points there's no objectives it's all
like you got to figure this out on you
know this is why watch strategy guides
back oh yeah prima baby yeah prima I
think for a head weapon we'll see which
one died yeah if you always watching
this in a cutout okay it's fine
regardless okay can't be back here right
not a chat if you all remember 5 has 210
direct my boy yeah let me out
maybe God talk okay here okay yeah there
you go it just had it was like a
prompting had to do nothing I went at
least get to the fight on the bridge
yeah man I'm a star sounds like you're
alone why don't you carry your famous
dude I'm a blitz ball stud dude have you
ever sprayed a game's hell yeah Albert
Brady games and prima guys oh yeah sorry
so before ff7 had both at both what
prima and brady guys oh yeah I had both
I would always went with primo yeah [ __ ]
that's the bow yeah yeah that's their
people that's like the dad back in uh in
five has 210 that's how they down do I
have to get along before I get that Oh
who's that oh it's your boy
number one legend over there checked
that Jack shot baby man Jack shot yeah
oh how he ain't got no leg where's
teammates at how come how come in with
his team dude he's supposed to roll wait
he's a star I never live up to man it's
like it looks like his oh his yeah his
lower lip is like let us know how the
audio is free all the balance between
our dumb asses and his belt this game
was wild though family this is the first
Final Fantasy on the ps2 generation that
generation are you trying to capture
four so a little inside baseball huh the
hot double-dip yeah
homies been trying to capture gameplay
while they're on stream man you got to I
know we got to be a fishing out here man
there's too much stuff going on in
office yesterday was oh my god yesterday
was just too much there's a lot
dude yesterday was the am/pm of a night
I was really hoping for Joker this
morning and then like tonight it's 5
o'clock or something yeah 30 or
something like that between 5:00 here we
go oh yeah this is okay this is just go
full game - we'll be back in a second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
drinking on the rooftop
we have a couple always for no spaces
[Applause]
that waters
[Music]
don't even need to make an NG
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the check shot right there
like Oh rad
[Music]
guess the kind of yes
oh yeah we back oh damn oh sorry I went
way back I meant to do game pit there we
go we're back it's alright it's like
starting the starting from the top yeah
oh we survived somehow
oh there's bad guys over here oh hey
what's up it's a tragedy do I know you
load it oh yeah I guess this happens a
lot faster than I thought cuz then
you're gonna get this this guy hey
what's up what's up time what's going on
hey it begins I had X an X - I missed
you yeah
he looks good he looks like like a grown
up Sora put you on here someone said meg
Ryan
oh hey that's stuff yeah that's a good
job Felix loving to kick that cutscene
yet for sure someone someone we know is
related to meg Ryan O'Reilly cousin yeah
like I say who but yeah that's pretty
cool yeah so we know yeah that's cool
my Claude it is on the switch yeah oh
yeah so that's yeah I guess I forgot to
say maybe I forgot to say that at the
time okay we're playing this on switch
that's why we're streaming it but I
suppose any day is a good day that
stream Fontaine season right okay man
though Wow past ten does does some wild
[ __ ] I played that when I was 10 years
old
blown away dude I love Offensive 9 but
it's heard a lot of good things about
that yeah I didn't play nine I didn't
play eight or nine only played seven it
was all over the place but it was no
period but ten is like yo this is like
the first this time I pass the of the
generation yeah which one was the FF
that was the MMO that stuff was 1111
almost provide to play 11 cuz my room
and college played I'm trying to like
help me hello lovely yeah
I'm playing I'm just started five fancy
14 well thanks for the sword it's been a
pretty dope I like yes barely nachus
there's like a crossover there's a
crossover event last week or something
here yeah can you give a synopsis it's
kind of like complicated
I saw the synopsis of this game yeah a
little complicated if you really break
everything down let's see you go ahead
I guess actually I opened up the
Wikipedia page I'm basically gonna be
mashing the attack button hey uh who
asked for that was that crime yes
so that damn this is a it's a lot
blitzball happens Titus is falls in love
with Yoona and she finds out that he's
uh I don't wanna spoil it straight he's
so much straight-up spoiled part of it
just now the ending okay yeah this game
is 18 years old but still it's kind of
like a it's on switch maybe it's the
first time I would say it's pretty cool
story-wise I would say if you're gonna
check it out just you don't want to know
that much about it yeah just because it
does like I said kind of get a little
wonky and wacky so it's pretty cool
though it is for sure I used to start
having those oh yeah what is what is
reality what I didn't like were those
temples though oh yeah yeah there's a
lot of existentialism in filefast ten
it's pretty good though like I don't
know maybe it's just me being like back
in the day on ps2 an old world could
look like this leo says Yoona's day
that's fair yeah dude yeah so that's
what I'm saying is like we go back to I
said earlier is that so Titus doesn't
seem that dope as a main character
because the rest of the cast yeah it's
so good like like Riku [ __ ] yuna's
dope or on stove loulou's know like
wakka wakka Doo wok is my boy my brother
and I were like yo they they got like
they got some Islander representation on
this game though so you have OverDrive's
I guess I have to use it
who's she like even though wok is kind
of like like a stereotype she's like
women oh yeah I got to some button
prompts beat me oh you [ __ ] up I
didn't I totally don't remember that I
totally for your knock them all out
yeah I wasn't even paying attention
although I guess it would have killed
the big thing faster though yeah is
there like a I get misty ones on
accident that's not good is there like a
way to up to saw ya ain't option yeah
you're right cuz uh
oh I should have overdrive yeah I was
wondering if it's like a just a button
because I know a Bronco I know you're
talking about like the summons and stuff
like they all happen faster oh we might
be in big trouble here it's all I'm
gonna die
no but I might have to all right here
let's try to not mess this I know aren't
like I was looking at the bars thinking
that was hell I was ready to press
buttons man I he only did 188 hey man
you got you got a tightest about to die
thing hugging the orange regular tag was
stronger than that
well I'm yeah on site oh it's okay
it's a percent alright damn he's like
percentage huh yeah so we good I just I
show just miss BAM an attack or on and
you know and my favorites that's fair I
both of those and Titus where my main
party walk every now and then and then
yeah I like Lulu cuz she got the she got
the magic touch she to me that's an
understatement
yeah and she holds a little Google right
she can hold like a tech tour oh yeah
she's like kissing the plushies she's
the she's the goth babe
oh I got it goth Bay from back in the
day that's one speed boost is so needed
the grind on this game is painful yeah
it's pretty painful some cases
especially to get something like the
weapon has oh yeah dat cam Reapers
telling me demi can't kill you it only
takes one fourth of life don't waste
oceans data
cool good shouts out here you want to
see if Oh settings yeah I kept using
some Oh what button settings audiodesk
see that doesn't make sense on the
button settings
oh well I got a good I know what they're
talking about though they have his feet
just speed it up yeah Oh sounds like one
of the cool things of a traveler spear
will save that's one of the cool things
of 5x12 remaster was being able to speed
up combat yeah the summons are dope yeah
yeah so that's why you know was always
in my party was to have this argument
Bahama that I had every seventy but yeah
we got to get out of here he's fine it's
just that with the pro controller well
I'm not used to like the lettering on
this controller yeah the ABXY is it is
not what I yeah like be for me is a I
still get the juice on that my in low
health oh no I think this took the
travelers fear heals you and I think I
think that's it oh they're flickering
oh they bout to use boo food and it's
been a while since I played a final ok
detect itis why would you do that
actually no I played Final Fantasy 15
went around the did you have to like
wake people up from sleep though oh yeah
yeah you can hit them - wait am i asleep
he's gonna have like low low damage
character do I feel like they're getting
replaced I think at this part I think
you just keep fighting until like ok
I'll get this Gabi there you go this
could be bad I was trying to aim for
that the whole time we can't do until
our on stelson
till daddy Oren tells you he's like [ __ ]
it I'll do it myself let me uh let me
scroll through the chat real quick let
me see what let me see what job insane
oh whoa that's
I can't read you can't look let me just
let me just admit it to y'all that what
do you need me read I know I'm just
saying I'm having trouble reading
glasses I told you that long time no I
could see it I just can't read some
dumbass let me go actually only fronts
everybody
I write good I don't speak good or read
good okay that's bad I guess let's see
is it 60 FPS seems like it I've always
had a bad eye than that so I defer to
you this uh this I think I want say
definitively but it sure looks like dad
its own ff10 had its own kind of like
wind music oh did I it's very once you
hear the first time you'll remember okay
it's like who has has somebody belts on
her dress
yes if there's anything you can rely on
me so orange Kakashi
oh hell yeah I realize that couples
helico kazimir oh gosh she's my boys my
favorite anime boy of all 2,000 years of
pain death will be readin pornos sure
his anti books back they I was like oh I
don't like that about the top see he's a
pervert but now like that's what's up
this is it Judaism what is that thing
it's gonna destroy a fenceless you know
who that thing is it's a booty hole
we're going in here oh yeah the man got
teleported oh this game is wild so he
dies there right no no maybe you should
play what or on oh what's that box
checked oh I can just send
I don't remember it's that word the
blitzball controls dude i hella don't
remember this part I can't spin the
camera oh yeah I was thinking like you
sure you still stick but nah yeah I was
like trying to pan the camera and I can
do it Oh who's that it's like music is
that young so young Titus sorry yeah
myself into voice actor for Titus let me
find out or on sounds hello familiar I
think whoever did yeah I mean look up
the voice camera but she's gonna be like
when to animate voice actors been inside
me especially a two different color eyed
girl named yeah let's see welcome this
beer X voice cast
see who got us here's Anime News Network
behind the voice actors I don't remember
this party there genius Arnold Taylor my
memories awful Matt Mackenzie did or
Tara Strong did Riku Tara Strong
that's she did a bunch of hey me about a
Oh a bird I know I think I know I'm
getting her confused with somebody else
maybe okay ESA is a game arnold taylor
for Titus Matt Mackenzie Orleans yeah
John DiMaggio did Wacka Wacka
that's weird
yes I reckon I asked good old brass get
Barberie Kumari is the Kumari so I was
right the first time you were close
close okay oh yeah this is like the less
exciting part right here whatever the
spam and hope for the best
okay guys where's it is there only the
dive button
oh no man at this rate we're gonna get
the ffx-2 yeah well I mean we're gonna
about like 15 more minutes till we
switch over to fine fancy 10 - I still
say we we should stick with this longer
I guess I'm confusing her with Tara
Platt oh the out of bed now we can
understand a little bit more of the
people's up the chat is got us on that
so anyway cool oh let me just dive wait
Ben's been said that we have a food
caterer today yeah we do how we have
teriyaki bowls why though just we're
gonna do that more often
ah snap you boy ain't got paper guys
want me to get a plate aside yeah oh yes
Ben please
otherwise we're gonna be stuck with
vegetarian stuff salmon important yeah
there's more than salmon or no salmon
pork or like vegetables okay yeah man
definitely pork no salmon for me pour
one out for for me Ben thank you Ben's
got these I wanna stream he's still got
her backs man oh that's walk you think
we're gonna get to walk Oh
I think this section might be a little
bit long cuz you got to go through life
sucks you got to go inside too I think
yeah you got to go through some fights
of them to fish things
[Music]
there are different games Gallo oh ten
and ten - ten is way longer than ten -
are buffered the switch is it in one
package it's in one package you just
toggle between the games oh and the main
menu right okay Michelle also I forgot
to say we're late today because like
somehow the dock that I was using biot
playing nice switch off eight men the
signals outside to switch dogs yeah you
got like 20 minutes to walk that alright
then we got to do it we're just gotta
get just get to walk up all right
preemptive right if we had that that see
combats overkill oh that's true we
should have made it so we could or use
it one shot everyone what are the menu
go you skip cutscenes I didn't see the
option but I didn't try either because
why would you skip the first one that's
a hell of an intro to a game dude what
do you sense something worse yeah that's
like the first little boss guy I think
we have to run from that guy is that
right no maybe you can use really fight
him no we peace out here's your live
item later I think we fight him way to
go stomach he's got a nut surgery man oh
you think that's the sack yeah it's like
a stomach he's a hungry boy
yeah he ain't got nothin in there I as
like his ribcage [ __ ] oh we just got a
straight fight oh really
maybe it's another one of those
something will happen eventually I hate
that [ __ ] 29 are we dead we are so dead
yep oh yeah just keep fighting until he
kills me he should kill me here yeah
okay let's holes doing half damage each
time assessing maybe okay yes if
something happens there's no way we're
fighting this guy right now I know you
have to bite him though I'm pretty sure
to get out of this area
sorry I got to stretch I was gonna keep
up on the chat sorry I know I know
people are out here Saints and face the
swamp at 10 is dope
whoa I'll see how is that can help us
here expenses ps2 graphics yeah its ps2
game so only some of this stuff is
remastered not all of it yeah
we barely made it sick
gray fox you up shots okay this is a
sixty hour ago oh dude like a plus I
spent like a hundred hours did I try to
unpack everything yeah yeah ready every
weapon if anyone in the chat remembers
dodging lightning strikes I did that no
not fun got do like 300 dodges in a row
in this place I did that [ __ ] because I
had time on my hands
cuz also masks tenure a halt I was older
than that but I also had a lot of time
on my hands
wait this good no no I wasn't 10 I was
11 because this game came out in 2001
what oh that was weird I was still the
dumbass
I haven't been able to skip any of this
so that's any indication yeah why would
you want to oh yeah I pushed those
strong boy over here he's an athlete so
professional athlete that is now your
cold the homeboy was stuck underwater
for a minute here son of my mixtape oh
is that a thing - I want to I want to
see everyone's favorite final fantasy
memories in Chad maybe five to ten if
you didn't play five face ten there huh
give me any problem say when Eric got
stabbed that's too easy
yeah that [ __ ] was heartbreaking I was
like dog she's tired but I got Flint for
fire and like halfway through the game
said and psych can't use her anymore
she was messed up dude I was I think
that was the first time like I hated a
villain in a game it was the tinder no
no no gender yeah Titus on tinder man
he'd be got all kinds of swipes tide is
annoying but homeboys fine Oh finally
remembers yeah eros getting stabbed yes
so yeah Sephiroth is like a first
character like I hate it in a video game
he's like Kefka in ff6 was was like a
comic villain like comically bad you
know comical evil and you fight
Sephiroth final form and he just keeps
casting g-d meeting on you and you're
just like come on
Gd meteor god damn meteor because like
it takes forever it goes through every
GD planet and you're right to the round
tables oh that's all so long by Elise
you're like yeah is my [ __ ] yeah yeah
you gotta watch it yeah I didn't well
now you kept using that [ __ ] I'm like
yeah I know I don't want to skip this so
it's tight but
Oh better now yeah I think my personal
favorite final fantasy memory is
probably dead I don't know the what's a
world of ruin and flap a c6 that was
dope I was like eight years old at the
time playing that no so uh Joey's online
yeah Yago stream cuphead tomorrow on all
probably um smash either smash or we
could just poke at noises tomorrow I
think a ton of the arrow comes out
tomorrow so many good games it's April
yeah I know so much dope stuff coming
alright let me see let me see what y'all
can't skip best-looking him 2001 yeah I
was on any console was true you dkm
Reaper he was right huh eh saying
helping buddy doing the lightning dodges
after found out there was that one hole
where every time you enter lightning
strikes immediately yeah that's super
helpful because it's like unpredictable
cadence or if you do it normal way Dan
come where it's has to dodge got the
item didn't user feels bad man oh I use
a bit you do it just to complete this
there wasn't even achievement evacuate
all like I never wanted to do riku's I
didn't do Kumari's I didn't do walk us
cuz I didn't want to do blitzball couch
oh here we go he's got top five yeah
poot Allah says top five ff6 FF 9 FF 7 8
9 10 I could
I would throw in four in there
personally but if you don't play for
then that's cool too they'll show how
means the ps2 was first time yes
gala game said that
well I things bigger than I thought it
was
did he did he laugh yet no we're not
there I wish that's what I were talking
about getting to you're probably not
gonna get there because that's a little
that's a bit deeper yeah it's pretty far
actually it's like a couple hours
gkm reaper says yunalesca fight in f10
when you find out about or [ __ ] not
gonna say anything but yes that is a
very good memory run I'm gonna run great
Fox other things talk to crime there
someone says they love cetera
Sephiroth TBS like I love to hate it as
what oh we got backup help us
TJ scoop says father who dad this
austere Bessie girl she's my I think man
is tough I think she's yeah she's my
best girl for passing this law there's a
lot of white boots of offense to you
gotta be you know because my tight
losing power that's what I'll say using
grenades
TJ screw bass this fantasy game okay for
the first one yeah all five biso each
5se game is its own contains stories
that's never like what continuation of
an earlier unless you do the spin-offs
like repent to steal to camera crew says
it's the best one we used one grenade
but still two back from him great box
yeah that's outside knights of the round
table twenty minutes um I didn't realize
I was Riku going again I forgot how fast
she is a fox
all right now great box crime saying if
you mix smash stages will you play them
maybe I don't know that seems like a it
sounds like a pretty dope community
Friday's typing I don't want to put that
on Ben and John Luke they're still going
through them kids yeah maybe it's some
somewhere down the line for you the cool
thing to do dude they have that people a
soundtrack song though you know it was
just a persona for OSP for yeah they
didn't use a Rena sound yeah the arena
has a variation of that song yeah don't
know I know that song we we don't we
don't we don't have to get into an
applet I can I can carry a whole live
stream telling you all about their house
how hyped I am about that yeah how do
you know we're not about to get raided
Titus yeah holding a buys hair what all
right we got one word mission Ryu cat
cuz smartest chat in the world for Vita
owners any grab the graphical difference
between the two that is yeah that's
something that the chat would have to
qualify
cuz I don't remember I played a
beautiful long time a while ago so
she's speaking another language hey
Bruno eres de Castro says calling cross
needs to remake yeah they do
kun kun no
damn she cold dude she could beat my ass
anything okay Ben it's got us some
plates some spring rolls pot stickers
teriyaki chicken okay I see you thanks
Ben
yeah there's not that many positives
though that's fine I saw the I saw the
count for it wait free is free you know
yeah I'm not gonna complain my Pete
likes to talk I only know never mind
like I say yeah all right we're on a
ship I don't know I got no we got 20 I
said we do closer to an hour for a 10 so
okay and then we'll do like 30 minutes
yeah okay even though I beat XQ twice
I like dressed beers and stuff like that
yeah look it's you know she can do a
wield and then you press buttons and she
shoots more bullets they should have
made tend to a character action game
like Devil May Cry for some now it's
boat then waka yep cool it's been a
while since play the game so I can't
exactly remember swim we got I got
swimming understand you to do bid she
couldn't stand me just gonna set that in
the first place all right
better than dying for reals oh you know
what I should say first in case anything
bad happens or weird oh there's more
books stuff to learn to crime we'll keep
that in mind what's that he's saying
some stuff about smash Stevie's why is a
now I know a little more as he cam
Reaper oh boy hey I see you is what I'll
say
it's telling me to go diagonal but can't
really do that well maybe I'd okay Oh
Jermaine uh sinnerman coming through
with the what's a translation of their
Kuno mean sorry nice okay make sense
sure there's two A's they're all right I
did skip that part
I guess sick alright sorry if I've been
talking over some important put scenes
that y'all want alright the spear great
for this is this path of Exile I know
right this was path of exile before path
of Exile yeah do the sphere grid was so
cool I love it I like why it was so
fulfilling to fill it out it may have
been the first time I played an RPG
no not some tree it's like traditional
RPGs just like oh you level up a
character and then they get skills
eventually and stuff like that so it was
one of the early examples of getting
some agency and how you build off your
character at least for me then it get
into PC games - a little bit later if
you like what you see maybe she'll hop
on that 5s to ten train man it's been 18
years so there's never been a better
time to play fine fancy
have a game on PETA so if I skip this I
mean it this is a like no okay if you're
itching to play five as you ten this is
a pretty cool way to do it but if you
have it on PETA if you have it on like
the ps4 like the back of Pat type stuff
then I guess there's no reason to do
this but you're interested see we're
fine fancy was 18 years ago let me check
it out trying to stand through this
y'all all right we got cheer hopefully
get some more nodes here I think we're
gonna be oh hell no you're not getting
nothing Riku how splits of pushing Ryu
cats as house blitz ball co-op and
multiplayer included I don't think so
like no is there yeah whatever that no
looks balls dope though I'm surprised
they didn't like I don't think they ever
did a spin off like standalone game they
should do that like even like a mobile
REE thing play but what's ball controls
are bad but I'm all about that life all
right
all right did this press Y all right how
do I get off the ship again that did you
tap the the travelers yeah I did this
already that oh man hell I forgot did
you talk to each MPC talked to Rican I
talked to Riku she did the spear thing
yeah yeah Roger all right
laughs I see 12 coming in two weeks
after a coup yeah turns out it's always
an MPC related thing that's how it was
back in these games man
she's got talked to each NPC but until
you uh progress progress the story it's
weird that I must be tripping like I
don't remember how to spin it I guess
you just can't spin yeah look I'm
swimming
hey homeboys a professional athlete man
how can he hold his breath for this long
though it's fine a fast man Oh random
encounters that's right that's uh that's
something you have to consider I see
here you're gonna hear though they don't
the second half yeah Nick blitz Paul
great again yes I happening and you
won't hear from me that's people talk
about octopod traveler in the chat PC PC
soon as I was originally a switch
exclusive but PC players can play that
dope 2.5 D RPG
Golden Week is coming but doesn't that
mean that they're gonna take a break on
like um mangas and animes and stuff like
what happened yeah Golden Week starts
right after persona super live the
two-day special live concert in Japan
that you wish you're going yeah I was
actually thinking about going to Japan
just for that yeah doing a Japan trip
around that so I got my tax return was
like I got bills to pay so that I'll
think about it and then I paid my bills
away I guess I can't go real life I
would have spent like like I wanna live
well the tickets rely a cheap they're
like $60 each for a general edition but
he got flight boarding food all that man
I wish I've had the resources I would
have done in a heartbeat it's come from
the streets yeah so yeah man we got we
got 12 more minutes until 12 o'clock so
we gotta get to trying to get walk get
to Waka Flocka over here
Zaman
yeah just hit it and it works it's all
be
[Music]
do you know what exact what Golden Week
exactly is like what like it's it's like
a
I don't know it's like I just know that
festivals it's like it's like a break
for artists and like animators and
spring break for everyone
there's Golden Week I'm like no take a
break
ambushed oh no it's a week from April
29th to early May containing a number of
Japanese authentic old so it's a series
of Japanese holidays Emperor's birthday
grand read a show add a constitutional
Morial day citizens holiday another
greenery day and children's day so it's
a series of holidays packed into you a
week it's not altered too different from
what we have Thanksgiving people out
here peace out during Thanksgiving like
bro there it still worked
oh yeah and then there's like the
Japantown out here in San Francisco
celebrates as well it's all cool stuff
happening in Japan salary
we heal or just yo-yo oh of course
whoosh Andrea cats got our back right
now in the PSN we'll have the best sales
of Japanese games to any shop that's
good to know
gray fox asked if you've ever been to
Japan I haven't been by I jus did you go
recently yeah I went last you and I'm
going in July oh snap didn't I convinced
my fiancee that we should go there for
honeymoon that's we're just basically
going to eat so there's a lot to do
what's up
in last last time we couldn't we didn't
get the chance to go to Ghibli Museum
but we were gonna go this time for sure
because we got tickets this time
Kukoc Queen it's a time though man you
gotta go when you I yeah I really need
to go can because it's like oh shoot oh
she got Crisco see is your boss
[Music]
okay so g/km reapers saying we're almost
there after this few minutes minutes and
then we got to Waka Flocka island yeah
steal another grenade ah but wow I
really can't bring it oh my god I'm
trying to keep up with childhood words
I'm seeing the word thank you getting
the crits Big KRIT you guys have extra
options for encounter rates no I tried
to do that just now and I'm assuming
you're talking about speeding up the
encounter type of situations DK we have
it no options but maybe maybe it was
like main menu options yeah we were
looking for that option but I know you
can't it's on ps4 or sorry yeah it was
on ps2 I remember
boxing I just save up and then like try
to like wait and hope for one of those
like really good deals
yeah or it's like I've seen it as low as
six hundred something really like that's
like really rare though it's really rare
I was looking at like nine hundred
something there was a in it was like a
couple months ago like three four months
ago there were tickets from SFO off to
from Japan Airlines round direct flight
it was like seven a little over seven is
cheap I don't remember when exactly but
she was like for like a couple days only
though and then they sold out man I'm
gonna withdraw my entire retirement fund
seven hundred is relative like pretty
fair if you can get seven four seven
hundred she can ever see it for like six
that's even better
yeah oh my head okay I'm head of
backstage to see if I can withdraw my
retirement fund yes it's like dog I
ain't never gonna retire so I'm as well
spend that money now not now not ever
you just gotta set aside try to set
aside like a hundred dollars a month and
then well but yeah we have 401ks yeah
yeah but the problem is like it's just
seven to eight hundred for the flight
you're not counting anything off look
look Dawg listen yeah I'm here for a
good time not a long time oh why
sportsman you want to live in the moment
you want to live that's just a check
that's basically a check to check I've
been living check the check there you go
for my entire life
so myzel Yolo this [ __ ] so there you go
yeah yeah seven hundred you just gotta
watch out for the deals I haven't been
to Kyoto yet poocho but I'm going this
July when I go back and then we're gonna
go to Nara for a day check out them beer
you know
temple mainly still staying around Tokyo
though gonna gonna have to have some
Wagyu beef again cuz thank you beef it's
not the same here I'll tell you that was
the first time I ever had Wagyu beef and
it was in Japan and that it just melts
in your mouth you don't have to chew it
can't you eat it raw
I think so but I don't mess with the
carpaccio's oh I don't do carpaccio's
I'm too scared
oh no I got pretty strong stomach so I
know but I'm just saying I'm I don't
know I've seen people eat like horse
meat raw too that's why I don't like oh
no about that I'm not gonna eat horse
I'm gonna take my horse the whole time
road and ride select no I'm not gonna
eat them all right
hook yourself with food Riku Oh Oh Jane
that was good they do you mean HD
remaster hey what is that would you say
that's like a pile of oh yeah it looks
like sloppy joe with guacamole was it
spicy what's the problem now you just
ate too fast the thing needs to be
melted or rented all day oh yeah
indigestion 7 remake never coming up I'm
really holding out hope they at least
show it again and you three this year
it's only a chapter 2 you know that
right yeah it's gonna be a Masada a
that's like that's amore but the
anticipation is just too much for it to
be like that Sagar
so we know Erica's 30x30 13 how old am I
I'm 14
[Laughter]
discount stitute as I'm laughing yeah
sure
now but the laugh though that's what
yeah that's all when him in you know
overlooking that one area right you
trying to help her out that's not
happening I was considering how long
I'll bet hater what are you from I'm a
blitz ball player
I'm just flexing on these hoes I'll find
you don't be like make that a four night
dance now don't get sued this will got
Tim's on I didn't realize how does one
short longer look at those zippers
though Ben would be happy with all the
zippers and he's got Tim's look that
shady stump out stomping on y'all so I
told her everything there was to tell
about African about life there blitzball
meet waka don't you meet walking Lua the
same time they're in the same area maybe
yeah maybe it's a little bit farther up
into the village but then I started to
wonder sick so yo my brother
this my girl oh yeah
oh those tight say something funny syn
[Laughter]
something like 13 or 14 I was talking
about 401 K I save it for the pager man
oh look out three steps ahead
yeah it's stuff in the streets y'all I
don't believe you captain bear tato
pants like sure he's like I wouldn't
doubt it hot topic sold some [ __ ] like
that though I don't know what you can be
good chopping up yourself so you get
like in the long shorts like and then I
still don't believe it that's tight
that's not tight don't do that I still
don't believe it I played in DD
hopefully do yarn pants like that man
time I trained but I'm with you your
songs yeah butterfly butterfly that's
low though yeah so that was like a
five-star rating I cannot remember
having rated BDR song it's all about
triple-a or double-a I'm losing I forgot
what a song was I was really bad at sync
soccer OVR legend Macker I remember max
300 those are the jams man I miss ddr2
yeah so yeah the I have those UNAM those
are functional none of these girls are
though like cloud on me for that [ __ ] I
don't know cuz like that's what you do
and your kids just clown on people first
he's got short pants pants shorts what
one girl says said to me she looked at
me she's like alright so my mom bought
me two pairs of the same pants so I wore
the heck you know same color though so I
came to next day wearing the same thing
it's just like you had the same pants
from yesterday and I was like no my mom
bought me two pairs and she's like they
smell the same I'm gonna like are you
gonna smell my pants right now
and it ever those third reason I'm
saying yes that's why I see different
colors well I can't make demands I take
what I can get for sure but like at that
point it makes it look like you have a
lot
I mean like it's the illusion oh we had
a uniform so we can only wear okay yeah
he went to a private school
no no hell no I'll do it my sander Kent
we still ahead they still had you wear a
uniform though lower like a color like a
colors white white shirts
what collared shirts and blue pants I
went to because I went to a private
school we had to wear it was a button-up
and they eventually became a polo polo
like way better and like blue slacks
poor [ __ ] they even that's why I'm
shocked that like I'm not saying that a
forceful wouldn't force you to wear
something specific it's just like you
would think there'd be less rules or
whatever yeah but we they didn't give us
uniforms we had to buy that [ __ ]
ourselves and we was already forced oh
what is that oh this is like some
Pacific Rim type stuff right now
kaiju
yeah that was and we still haven't
gotten to walkie and it's already 12 are
we gonna get to 10 - yeah I see at least
the beginning of time
okay Fox gotta head out Luke later he's
out man I'm right
oh this is why right we get washed up to
see oh yeah yeah if you don't any Rico
again for a while in the desert area
refused other alphas better-looking this
is more for like being underwater I
think Oh JC Denton she's in the chat is
this call of duty yes a bond come on
come on come on flaca Waka Flocka no he
didn't say that ground rica rico is
surplus Riku what Riku is Sora plus
Rican thank you is practically nude in
x2 you will see is kind of similar to
what you'd want
oh oh hey what it I know that feeling
yeah I always come back to wait later
boy how many people got Mohawks because
of him oh the don't the four hops
let me show you my trick oh yeah dude go
off he's flexing on hitting with a check
shot kind of looks like Jan's here yeah
sure I'll ask Jan after this you're like
laka yeah got that Walker actually now
this is his is like straight up just
that just one you ever had frosted tips
back in the day yes I sure did court she
did all the Asian boys back then they
had Friday and then long time ago I had
the part down the middle yep it was the
part down the middle then the frosted
tips spiky hair spiky hair after that
this is the progression of Asian
hairstyles and now we're in the coma
over face yeah comb-over is last
probably the longest I would say yeah
cuz it's professional but also it's good
comb-overs took over all the holes oh
good all Filipinos back in San Diego and
I was like I'm not getting Koval come
over I'd email a boy hair for like 10
years he said she said stator boys and I
said see you later see you later boy
what
sure that works like I walk is the only
one I know everyone's got like template
faces this one is dogs ain't got to you
but you're still alive it's Gibraltar
praise be to Yemen wow yeah that's
that's that i'ma start doing that [ __ ]
you say doubts are like trash trash
trash they are the like they're the
Lakers it's ball we don't have no look
we're all I guess I'm wrong sorry we
gotta we gotta go yeah okay we got waka
so that's do you want to go fullscreen
back here or
you have to reset this will do I know no
care per second okay is there a way for
me to know there's no faster way there's
got to be a faster way right wait how
come I can't go camera it's not letting
me click it oh yeah yeah hey there go
all right we're gonna switch over 10 -
real quick so don't go anywhere
let's see what are we all been saying
how y'all enjoying Final Fantasy 10
boxing sighs don't do drugs
yeah don't do that only main characters
have HD yeah drugs are fine in certain
circumstances prescription I was like
what are you saying right now man I
think you switch back okay damn I look
really orange today let's go you
Filipino you're just generally tan all
right so this is I didn't even know what
eternal calm is oh oh what the hell oh
yeah yeah like who's pretty much wearing
this similar right sure ah I don't know
about Yuna and the booty pants though
like that's like I told you it's
dressier man you like you change out of
it I've been changing the other stuff
yeah it's like going into the Metaverse
yeah but different that one look at
these little knobs on this [ __ ] before
now that what you have is better
oh this arm was good too there is some I
don't have any loads you got no new game
here all right
now we have moved on to if you're just
joining us for playing five hits 10 and
final place - 10 - because it's out on
switch yep
is that yesterday oh yeah we're a day
late but uh it's all good we're doing
World War the affair oh it's like it's
it's like the same things
oh no this is a concert yeah go full
game oh hell yeah all right we'll be
back in a sec we'll be back after this
little concert from our girl here
[Music]
Leszek
it's show time girls so this is not my
face
[Applause]
FMV arsenite tempest email or mat paws
specifically but that's where music can
go in 10-15 years now we keep hopping
[Applause]
or just popped oh we went from classy to
the Sailor Moon yeah Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you can't take this one seriously at all
[Music]
[Music]
okay not to be that like a rebel
[Music]
under any king
[Music]
okay it was not bad coming off at that
span in place a very different
experience but what can I do for you
is this something like ekata hikaru yeah
[Music]
pain Oh
jessie child refused like kelly rowland
Wow what and then well you know pioppi
Michelle Kelly Rowland's the next event
right yeah he's like the chase
she's like the JC of anything yeah oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how we start off x2 that's right
what can I do for you you know chill on
the stream with you it's been it's been
a good time man
Final Fantasy 10 intent to is a good
time I remember like with the dress
beers you're supposed to like swap in
between them like for max I don't know
so the the the cutscenes were great but
when you start to see it in like in
dimension it looks apparently eternal
calm if you watched eternal calm before
this it makes sense of why like nope
happen alright you did that again cool
oh let's watch it back on our own time
oh look putting a rhythm game look I I
absolutely love the persona dancing
games so I can't hate on a final fantasy
10 to like yeah
oh man ecstasy are you all right they
attack at the same time what is wait
what's happening oh shoot casting Lanie
we're fighting right now
yeah but like why why because you'll see
okay I don't remember much about this
game other than like its diet
oh she a time that actually online even
over there
ah crap I didn't casually because it
sure is
I'm gonna steal yeah I got a high potion
crap I'm not really chaining it's my
fault online yes this is like I'm Greek
bit like a musical like a show it's not
just a concert we win did it Oh dancing
all night yeah well my favourite rhythm
games of all time
see why is it question mark question
mark because it actually psych that's
the wrong you know and then I heard it's
a phony the fraud fraudulent yeah okay
not okay I was like this we just saw
this menu oh yeah we got to relearn the
game again I'm trying to spam and I
won't play I'll play 10 - now [ __ ]
yeah I mean if anything switch makes it
way easier as you can like I think I
like Riku cuz she has bad posture
slouching yeah um all of my girlfriend's
have had bad posture that's what you're
into Hosko Leo says
[Music]
that's a different thing we should react
at best voices actor interview I hope
I've ever done a voice actor interview
I love Grenada news it's the way for
that I'm sure there's a bunch of stuff
on gamespot but personally I don't know
if I his riku wifey it is for Mike yeah
yeah recursing groovy ah correction dang
it
someone said my god this is a ps2 ps3
ps4 and PSVita announces what I stole a
budget grenade not even a good grenade
oh yeah so when I wanted us to steal
grenades so we done did it oh so from
the other girl whoops
the she goon is what they're called they
really have we seen Lulu yet no we
haven't
no it's wakka you like it was like past
the walk apart is long and Lulu over
here hey fraud
Jonathan will tell you oh I see dual
wielding guy who does down like
Rocksteady and Bebop dude she has like
swirls in her eyes never noticed that
before now you see that yeah her uh oh
who dat doh it was a real one yeah oh
damn Dante over here yeah oh that's what
I'm saying like this game should have
been a it was a character action game
about whether you completed every dress
beer
can't remember my original playthrough
but maybe ooh
Oh stylish Charlie's Angels - yes yrp
Europe we just played arm switch because
it came out yesterday on switch yeah now
we just want play for season giggles sit
excuse pretty much Wow refuse pushers
really bad to the point where it's like
I don't know if I'm into it anymore what
she's in attack mode
oh I screwed up I screwed up and
impressed I didn't press why are enough
oh yeah all the all bed people have
green swirly eyes some Lord some lore
for you see there's a combo combo
offered trick they're happy this is
really easy
hmm why RP you know takes the spotlight
and smash now you got Joker wait oh yeah
Yunnan smash would be pretty cool oh oh
it's fake agilent fake ass she called
[Music]
it's me it was me all along
sick nailed it
what what was she speaking Japanese I
know L how that happen I have to go to
music all right this panel from a Blanc
power breaker way to mode hold on
I must switch into my popstar attire
this is dope dude this battle system and
all I am this is what I'm talking about
that's the darkness dance ooh I stole a
silver bracelet that's pretty good
actually
Oh everyone's how about Joker and smash
don't get me started don't don't do this
to me
Ben's asking if we talk about Joker food
Joker's can't close the menu touch the
touchscreen I'm preventing myself from
doing that because I don't want to do
rail on the stream too much as we're
playing Final Fantasy we'll get to take
a picture well get the Joker and smash
at a later time there's nothing left
email is the most important thing that's
happened recently like PS 5 news
yesterday
now Xbox news no but Joker come here
address you here everyone because why
not
let's do it she's a warrior now one
thing I will say about the Joker reveal
yesterday is that the smash bros is
going to great lengths to do like a lot
of dope stuff to pay homage to persona 3
4 & 5 like they're going they're doing
extra they didn't have to but they're
doing it and I'm here for it there's no
order bad pain be at the this is wild
oh damn oh so dope alpha stay in
formation to look at unit is like you
can't touch this crime I feel you on
that one man
wonder if you bring little bring on
fantasy xiii trilogy to switch that'd be
pretty cool i played 13 for a little bit
I was like I wasn't into it it's
unfortunately yeah derp dee cambrie for
what's a favorite summons nice and round
table for 5-7 even though it's 20
minutes long crime yeah be skins - they
got the p3 p4 protagonists and as mieze
oh yeah introduction is this Sailor Moon
close
mission complete
can't wait for to put Kiryu in smash hey
man me too Ben
bloop oh x2 why not play or ten - why
not playing ten we played ten for an
hour yeah earlier in the stream but we
have to switch over for ten - because
you just gotta go about like ten more
minutes
yeah of this dopest more dressier action
no one loves fancy
I love I don't realize she had the jects
logo on her skip through it but it's you
want to hear all no oh yeah this guy
death will just yeah the money
this game is so dope this game is anime
as [ __ ]
alright what's your new invention my
dear no shinra's and I'll bet he's a
real whiz kid holy crap is so a lot I've
done I don't want to see my news sit in
every fond fantasy oh that's right Sydal
isn't he this is it that's that's a or
intend as well there's a sit in every
fantasy this is basically all wrong
her hair is dope oh yeah now she keep it
up wax I can't I'm still trying to find
the best hair product I've tried like
ten different things
yeah oh we got running animation to him
man I don't know changing outfits is
dope it's like there's combo stuff in
this game yeah and someone was saying
like oh they they were less close and
they feel so protected you know what
what do you so anime game great the
great cornerback Deion Sanders once said
look good play good play good feel good
feel good way to know it's [ __ ] yeah
your clothes look good feel good feel
good play good play good get paid good
get paid good lifted everything wrong
yeah oh yeah you can sleep here I talked
to the bartender I'll turn up dude look
at all those bottles pop bottles look at
that soup oh sure another Florida or
yeah the soundtrack is groovy dawg yeah
I'm into it
so we're at the bridge
it is kind of like an enormity I guess I
miss I miss the Normandy I miss walking
around that thing oh it's the engine
rooms where you can talk to tally and
this one there's something down there
Jack ooh both chests oh man we coming up
there's no dialogue choices in this game
right there's all linear I think so yeah
crime was asking me feel like that a
remaster for 8 yeah I would like that
with squall sleeper yeah what was the
girl's name
rinoa yes yeah 8 was 8 was the first
game I played when my family moved to
San Diego so I remember like sleeping on
a air mattress playing funfest you hate
with my brother man again was dark
though I was too young to understand
what was happening
no don't lie factory COO this whole time
Wow well at least we got a tour of the
ship so box man I saw you I was like
what go yet
Hey oh yeah Joey was on line if you're
gonna stream cuphead get his ass on here
again it's okay Joey I know you got a
new job right one take a day off chill
with us
still analyzing huh
analyze analyze analyze as well take it
easy till buddy get some leads so do we
have to go rest
go sleep those gang captains captain's
cabinet got four more minutes yeah it's
uh oh I didn't come out here dope look
at this damn tight I think you have to
go there sometimes to do story dialogues
I want PlatinumGames to make a final
fantasy ten to that trigger action yeah
that's what I want
okay you play like Bayonetta I believe
you go to the top of shipper dress I
think it's a rest at the bar keep okay
thanks for being we don't have a no
prima Guides no more so y'all gonna have
to help us over there and chat your
touch what do we scream yesterday World
War Z or Z that's sadly we couldn't do
co-op though their servers are having
problems or like they're having problems
across the multiple platforms oh snap
I was capped at 30 that's good isn't it
nice that was ice warning
like I said I don't my eye for that kind
of stuff not so good all right the
remastered parts of it is like if you
look at like the kit like a main
character details
they're like much better than yeah but
it's not like a lot different than the
it doesn't it doesn't affect the the
spirit of the game yeah still very much
it's like a fresh coat of paint on some
people yeah what he's still analyzing
[Music]
taking I go to the top of the ship yeah
how many times y'all got sleep can't be
sleep maybe I was supposed to hold like
X at the or like presses button at the
sorry y'all if not whatever we showed
you the combat system and this and I
changed into multiple outfits it's been
uh it's been a while since the Internet
can you interact with that thing I
wanted like Titanic this hold me check
there's nothing
or maybe we have to buy something from
the barkeep well maybe this is 60fps but
the animations aren't this is yes yes I
don't know it's hard to tell I will go
back to the bar key
my eyes are failing me these days talk
to pain and Riku I heard the both of
them unless maybe it's different now
that I've rested sure
then talk to Riku this brother okay
sick thank you maybe it's because I
didn't talk to riku's brother which I
would imagine is the pilot
of course
thanks Leslie sick Ohio he just gives me
three primary sick time the party doll
[ __ ] I got my dress beer - I'm down
party my buddy you still analyzing still
analyzing winning the party
this might be where dad's sick oh no no
I know nothing gotta talk to everyone
I've talked to everyone okay okay hold
on all that you know what we didn't do
we didn't entertain the boys creature
creator thing yeah that's why that's
highlighted huh yeah
Ave okay say no there you go
cool trap pod do we have a frame counter
odd I don't think so because if we did I
would have used that for a lot of the
lot of things I you know tech analysis
I've done in the past but since we don't
I have it a the 60fps yeah but the
animations I don't think are have been
like never remastered like the animation
so late screens will move at 60fps but I
guess the character models just don't
haven't changed or the animations I'm
changing oh yeah
Ramon Morrison yeah I just I just talked
to him about the creature
Holmwood now oh wait now go rest now go
rest
all right that's it that's it that's it
right all right sorry that's fine you
guys get the general gist of it I I
don't even know how I got through this
game to be honest with you but yeah
thanks Michael for joining me of course
cells live on x2 HD remastered
stream it's been a while since which
yesterday 10 and 10 to out off switch
it's been a while since I'm going on a
stream so like once I hit one hour I'm
like oh man this is this is exhausting I
don't know how you do this almost every
day man it's fine it is fine I just kind
of yeah I don't know I would say if you
haven't played it and you have a switch
this is probably like one of the best
ways to do it just because you can bring
it along with you anywhere do some stuff
hit the save and then like come back to
it later or if you got a Vita I'm saying
Vita means life so Vita I love my Vita
man snap oh yeah that's yeah that's it
come back tomorrow will either be
checking out katana zero or maybe Joker
oh boy see ya joker is coming to smash
tonight night camp your eyes out on that
at 5:30 but don't quote I said that I
think there's like a Nintendo website
said 550 and 730 between those times oh
oh I'm sorry
keep your eyes out on that we're gonna
have a bunch of content around that
because that's what matters most to you
up to the world when it comes to video
games so yeah we do a lot of dope stuff
here on GameSpot though yesterday was a
wild day with Tom my ps5 with Tom bought
new Xbox stuff but talk about smash bros
and new content there so stick stick the
game spawn all that dope stuff we even
had a boy or our boy Jeff Gerstmann go
through talking with y'all about the PS
5vm it's one of the video check it out
definitely check that out
Jeff is back on games behind ya to some
degree I guess yeah and yeah we got big
games going on next week
obviously MK is on the way om case right
around for combat cast on Monday Shao
Kahn trailer drop today check that out
Days gone coming up soon as well so you
know a lot of stuff to look forward to
kind of towards the end of April there's
no longer a slow season for video games
because they're still rolling through it
man yeah Pope didn't send us out of here
all right row right there yeah all right
n we have address beer I guess Wow okay
well thank you all for joining us we
always have fun with everyone in the
chat so come back next time peace out
[Music]